- So Ayesha Ramachandran
is Associate Professor
of Comparative Literature.
Professor Ramachandran
is a literary critic
and cultural historian
of early modern Europe.
Her recent work focuses
on Europe's relations
with an expanding world.
And her first book on that topic,
"The World Makers" was awarded
the MLA Scaglione prize
in Comparative Literary Studies.
The Milton Society of
America's Shawcross prize
for the best book chapter on Milton
and the 16th Century Studies Associations
founder's prize for the
best first book manuscript.
In addition to literary and intellectual
historical questions, she is interested
in early modern maps,
particularly world mapping,
the history of science and
technology, early modern empires,
and the rich visual archive
of illustrated books
in the period.
Her current book project
"Lyric Thinking: Humanism
Selfhood Modernity"
argues for the central importance
of lyric form and language
in shaping new intellectual
possibilities for the self
in the early modern period and beyond.
Christophe Schuwey is
assistant professor of French.
Cause I'm gonna apologize in advance
I took French for reading
and so I can't speak French.
So I'm gonna blunder
a few of these things.
But Professor Schuwey specializes
in the literature and culture
of 17th century France.
His research focuses on the book market,
fashion and marketing
in the classical age,
the circulation of news,
the making of cultural hierarchies
and cultural transfers,
especially between England and France.
He's the author of and here
I'll read the translation only,
"Painting the Times Through
Comedy: an introduction to
"Molière's "Misanthrope" and "Tartuffe""
and coauthor of three critical editions,
the Nouvelles Nouvelles by Donneau de Visé
Le Parnasse réformé by Gabriel Guéret
and a forthcoming edition
of the Alcoran de Louis XIV.
Professor Schuwey is thus also active
in the field of digital humanities,
which we'll hear more about today.
With the mentioned critical editions,
multiple databases including
the birth of dramatic criticism
in 17th century France.
Again, I'm reading the translation
and "Book Interfaces:
What Digital Humanities
"can do for Literature."
Please welcome professors
Ramachandra and Schuwey.
(crowd clapping)
- Oh, perfect. Okay.
Take it away.
- Yeah. Can we put away our mask?
Yep. Thank you. Thank you.
Well, hello everyone.
We're very glad to be here.
Ayesha and I, to talk a bit
about what is available to you
in terms of resources and
help about this thing,
that is terrifying thing that
is called digital humanities.
There has been a lot of
debates around institution
on what is digital humanities
as always with any fields.
There are questions of power.
There are question of resources
that are at play here.
So there are multiple definitions
of digital humanities.
And one definition that
could be representative
of what we are doing at Yale
is maybe the simplest one,
the uses of computers to study,
contribute to and discuss the humanities.
So what do we mean by that?
Maybe the best one, the
best way to address that
is to talk a bit about our own stories
and our relationship to
the digital humanities.
So I came to digital humanities
because during my PhD,
I start using old 17th
century French books
that were not available in my hometown,
which is Switzerland, Fribourg
but that was only available in Paris.
So it was easier for
me to use Google Books,
to access them then to
go to Paris every week
to check out these books. Right?
So I started to use
digital versions of books,
and then I started to use plain
text search in Google Books
to find things that was in
it that I was interested in.
And then I use library catalogs,
digital library catalogs
to start to find trends.
Is it this word,
a buzz word between 1660
and 1670, for instance.
And all this kind of every
day application of computers
to the study of humanities.
Right? So when I arrived in Paris,
I suddenly realized that
there was a whole field
called digital humanities,
where we were making graphs,
where we were making trees,
where we were making maps, et cetera.
And I both discovered how useful
this kind of representation
and new approaches to the humanities were,
but also how they can sometimes
take all the resources
and drive us away from the actual work,
which humanities and
what the actual questions
questions we're interested
in, in the humanities.
So this is why I wrote this
book called "Interfaces"
which is a book that says...
Actually it is as much digital humanities
to use a library catalog
than to make a big data
project that will analyze
topic modeling across two
century of texts, right?
All of this is using
the computers to change
our relationship and work and questions
to the digital humanities.
Because as useful big data is,
the transformation that
digital humanities is creating
for the humanities is a
kind of everyday thing.
The fact that we're accessing resources,
that we are writing, not
using a pencil but a computer,
is changing the way we're working.
Is changing the way we're thinking.
Is changing the question
we are trying to address.
And this is the approach
that kind of minimal,
but as inclusive as it can be
approaches that we try
to rely on here at Yale.
- That's actually funny.
I didn't know Christophe's
origin story. So now I do.
And actually it's very funny
because I have a similar origin story.
I was writing my dissertation,
trying to track the
appearance of the word world
across a body of texts over two centuries
and did the same thing.
I was like, well, this was,
of course in the early 2000s
before the kind of huge
blowing up of big data searches
and large kinds of...
It was the early days
of the Google and Gram.
And I began to think, wow, what
are the databases of texts?
And how do we begin to
actually begin to sort
and understand empirically if we can track
these set of thematics and concepts
lexically across multiple texts.
And I did some of that
work for my dissertation
and then quickly became disillusioned
with the kind of grand possibilities.
It was kind of the early days of DH Steel
and kind of moved away
from the digital humanities
in part, because I asked a question,
I think, many humanists ask, which is,
do I really need to go to
computers and count things
in order to answer interpretive questions
that are actually at the
heart of the humanities?
And so, in what ways is digital humanities
or the promise of databases, big data,
text mining, spatial analysis, et cetera,
really just a kind of grand
dream of making the humanities
more like the sciences,
as opposed to actually
asking deeper methodological
questions about what these tools can give,
kind of traditional
questions in the humanities
and support kind of traditional
training in the humanities
which most graduate students
actually still get today
and which is what I
teach in my own classes.
I found my way coming back,
interestingly to the digital humanities,
after a long phase of what I would call
a kind of skeptical crisis,
which is having used these methods myself,
I sort of thought, well,
this is really not helpful.
This has just become a thing.
I'm not interested in a kind of scientism
in part because my own work
is in the history of science.
And then I found myself in my new project,
which is about lyric poetry
and thinking about global lyric poetry
on a kind of, you know,
scale that is impossible
to look at bibliographically
by an individual person,
to think, well, okay.
So do computers actually
have something to tell us
or help us in synthesizing,
putting together
and thinking differently about
the objects of our study.
And one of the things
that's important here,
I think, about this definition,
which in some way is deeply simple
but also incredibly complicated is,
computers just think in two ways,
yes or no, zero or one, this
is not how humanists think.
So if you wanna ask the computer
to do something for you,
any kind of analytical work,
you have to re-craft the side of question
as a humanist you were
asking a computer to do.
And this is true for super computing,
This is true for like
the very basic question
of is this yes or no, on or off.
There's a kind of powerful binary
in the way in which computers work.
And so to re-imagine
bibliographical questions,
what is a poem?
Does this count as this kind
of poem or that kind of poem?
Requires you to ask really
profoundly precise questions
about the object of your study,
which often as humanists,
we're not trained to ask.
So I found my way back to
this project I'm working on
right now, which is a
census of lyric poetry
for the early modern
period in a global scale,
which is deeply collaborative,
deeply humanistic,
but has also forced me in the
process of just articulating
what is my data model
to ask questions about poetics
that usually people who
write about poetry don't ask.
And that has produced a lot of
interesting intellectual work
almost alongside and
separate from the business
of actually trying to figure out
how would I build a data
model to talk about poems?
And how do we analyze large
scale volumes of texts
to find poems that we may
not otherwise have catalog?
Right. So my origin story
in some ways is a story of
both fascination skepticism
and then a kind of
almost reluctant return.
But a reminder that digital humanities
is not just about
learning a bunch of tools,
which we're gonna tell
you about in a moment.
But also about an encounter
with a different paradigm of thinking.
And a paradigm of thinking
that can exist alongside
and in conversation with
the ways in which humanists
are traditionally trained. Right?
And I think Yale is in
some ways a great place
to do that kind of conceptual work
because we're not an
institution that's invested
in the fantasy of the tool.
We are an institution that is
deeply embedded in thinking
for a logically, thinking
in comparatively,
thinking in all of the
kind of traditional ways
in which interpretively in
which humanists are trained.
So how do we take that
traditional training
and think about this new
or so-called new method
and what can it do for us?
And I think that this is a place
with a lot of resources for that.
So we thought we would turn
briefly to just talk about
some examples of the kinds of
digital human humanities work
that people are doing in our
fields in the humanities,
and which are similar to Yale.
So we'll just go back and forth between us
and start by looking at...
Christophe's has kindly put a map here.
This is for my pleasure. Thank you.
A lot of my work work on mapping,
the history of mapping in the 16th century
began actually with looking at maps online
before I actually went to the libraries
that held these books.
And there's, I mean,
there's a lot we can say
about the relationship
between the digital collection
and the actual object,
and that's a whole field of study itself.
But Yale because of its
extraordinary collections
is a place in which the
interface of digital
and an actual object is
being thought about deeply
across a number of different collections.
And that is one place in
which digital humanities
is powerful, alive, and
kind of being made every day
in our teaching and research here.
- Yeah. And I would like,
sorry, to add about that.
As much as we can think
about the relationship
between the original object
and a digital version of the object,
the alternative before digital humanities,
where the critical edition in
its wide standardized paper.
So accessing those texts,
those maps, those material,
even to a photograph that
is not a perfect replica
of the original object is
already bringing in back
a materiality that was almost lost
for many, many, many decades before.
And this is, I think
something that we humanists
are perfectly trained to think
about and to explore further
than just saying it's bad
or it's the revolution of the world.
It's more complicated than that. Right?
Another kind of project
that is digitally managed
is digital edition.
I think the screen here can
be used not only to replicate
again the original object,
but to try off new visual experiences
and new relationships to our object.
Trying, for instance, to
rethink the very concept
of the footnote, which
is still very widely used
in digital editions today.
A footnote, and in French
it's une note de bas de page.
So it's related to the page.
Doesn't make any sense anymore.
So how can we think
reference in a different way
in a digital world?
How can we bring some sort of
different reading experience
than the linear one from
the start of the book
to the end of the book, knowing
that often with many books,
we are actually not
reading them differently.
This is also something that
digital editions can do
on the top of making
texts more accessible,
more easily accessible, that can be a read
if we need to hear this
text instead of reading it,
et cetera, et cetera.
- So the next one?
- Yep.
- All right.
Do you wanna do this one?.
- I can start and then...
- Yeah
- But so all this is not to
say that these are most visible
part of the digital humanities
that are graphs, maps, trees
to quote from commodities
book is not important. Right?
But I think it should be
taken into a more general
broad approach that it's
another way of looking at things
the same way a digital edition
or a photograph of material
is another way of looking at something.
Here's another way of looking at our text.
And sometimes it doesn't answer
any question that is useful.
And sometimes it does
answer many questions
that we need to know,
and that were very
difficult to answer before
and both are true.
- Yeah. And I would just add to that here,
looking at these charts,
that one of the things we don't talk about
when we talk about digital humanities
is the question of data literacy, right.
And what that simply means
is what kinds of objects
are data for humanists?
And what is the relationship between them?
and how is that the grounds
of a kind of analysis
that allows us to be
critically self-reflexive
about what we are actually doing.
Right. So having to think
about humanities objects
in terms of data, and to think about
what kinds of relationships
we're setting up with them,
which is the kind of conceptual
work of a digital humanities
that produces things like this, right?
The setting up of a corpus,
the setting up of a database,
these things seem deeply
ordinary in a certain way,
but they also require a level of thinking
that is not the same thing as
like reading a novel, right.
It's thinking about what
do we do with that novel
when we wanna create a kind
of database of characters
or count certain kinds of relationships.
You got the next one?
All right. So the other
thing that's very familiar
to humanists in digital
humanities is text mining
or sort of the kind of Corpus searching
that both Christophe and I
did as our origin stories
of digital humanities.
This is an example from
the early print lab.
A project at the University
of Washington at St. Louis
to which is a deeply tagged
corpus of early modern texts
which can be searched in
various ways using python
and other kinds of programs
to understand relationships
between texts, words and
text and so on and so forth.
This is the kind of deep textual searching
that a lot of students will
use or should think about using
in their projects.
However, the learning curve to get there,
and the kinds of things
you can do with them
is not in substantial.
Alright, this is me again. Okay.
So this is actually an example
of a project that was piloted
here at the digital
humanities lab at Yale.
It's kind of extraordinary
project for image analysis.
So one of the things
that is an affordance,
I think, of the digital humanities now
is the ability to analyze
very large amounts,
not just of text, but also of images
through the use of neural networks.
And PixPlot is a tool that was built here
at the digital humanities
lab in order to do that work,
to identify sort of analyze relationships
between very large numbers of images.
And this is something that
is actually used widely
in the sciences for various reasons.
I mean, particularly in like biology
to look at organisms and
sort of shifting chemistry
from molecules and for electron analysis.
It's application in the
humanities is very different
because of the kinds of images
and the questions we wanna
ask of images. Right?
And so PixPlot is one example
of the kind of large scale
image analysis that can be done.
And I will say in my own project right now
with the lyric poetry and
exploring the possibility of...
We have many, many pictures
of manuscript pagers,
and because of the shape of a
poem that is so distinctive,
can we use image analysis to
identify poems in large scale
manuscript corpora that
are digitized into images
that are not already OCR and
we can't actually search them
textually because they're
in handwriting, right?
So in what ways do text
and image merge. Right.
For us to think differently
about the nature of our object.
- And this is a point, for instance,
where those kind of
connection and resemblance
that suddenly the computer shows us,
maybe some of them are not relevant.
- Yeah
- But then this is the ability
of the digital humanities
to raise question.
If we decide that it's
not relevant, then good.
Not a problem.
But sometimes, also being
able to see so much material
in such a short time span
is also a way to create
some relationship that we
didn't see, that we missed
that the critic miss until, until now.
should we go to our next one?
- Yes. Yeah
- Something also that is transformative
is the access to data.
That's the very definition
of digital humanities.
But the fact that we have databases,
themathic databases of,
for instance, performances
in the past or, Canterbury performances,
is also a way to access things
that were available somewhere.
But that would require a
tremendous amount of work
to get it together.
And every time the question change,
then you had to go again to the archive
and ask a different question, right?
And I don't think that any mathematician
would say that computer
just made things easier.
I think that when you can
certainly ask question,
that takes a couple of seconds to answer
versus months to answer,
then you deeply change
the way you approach and
work with the humanities.
We'll do.
- No. It's good.
- So very quickly because I
see you're running out of time.
Another thing that digital
humanities work does
is large various kinds
of spatial analysis.
This is the project in classics,
it's the digital and
Atlas of the Roman empire,
which is a lot of people use.
The production, to think about
the relationship of space
and sort of humanistic objects.
Again, produces many different
kinds of spatial analysis
possibilities from the use of
maps or the creation of maps
to the use of GIS, to
map various kinds of data
on to kind of various
sorts of spatial locations.
That's the kind of work
that a number of people
in the humanities are increasingly doing.
And that again, produce the
ability to ask and answer
different kinds of questions.
- So, this circles back to
something that we touched on,
digital humanities, but
also humanities as data.
Actually what digital humanities
allows us also to think
is that what we consider as humanities
is also sometimes data
that can be represented
in a different way.
That makes us get away from
the only textual narrative
parroting to something different.
Sometimes what we think
is purely humanistic
is actually data and can
be better represented
in different form of
data, maps, et cetera,
Then sometimes narrated in a text.
So do you want to add something?
So question for you very more
concrete. What do we have?
(mumbling)
What resources do we have at Yale?
That's the technical issues?
So there is many initiative at
Yale for digital humanities,
people doing digital humanities at Yale,
as you will find out.
But there are two, I
would say main resource
that you should think about.
So the first one is the Yale DHLab
that is in the Sterling Library.
The Yale DHlab offers support
for any of your project.
You go there during your office hours,
whatever your level
is, how precise you are
or how un-precise you are, you go there,
you talk with them about your
project and they will help.
They can offer grants
to start your project.
They can offer technical support.
They can offer a wide array of support
and both technical and
advice and development
and technology, et cetera.
And please, if you never
did anything digital
go there because this
is made exactly for you.
If you already know how to do it,
then you don't need DHLab, at some point.
The other one is the more,
let's say scholarly
theoretical initiative.
This is the initiative that
Ayesha and I are chairing
sort of DH@Yale, which is
trying to build a community
around this question of DH.
So a place where anyone
can come and discuss,
find other people who are
interested in digital humanities.
We have a reading group.
The first meeting will be November 30.
If you're interested,
please write to any of us
to be added to the list
where we try to understand
where is the field,
where is the field going?
What we can do with digital
humanities, find support,
find project that you might be
interested to collaborate in.
And so please join whatever your level,
whatever your interest and we
would be happy to have you.
- I just want to close us out
by saying that Yale humanities is powerful
for its connection to its collections,
its long histories of training
here that go back centuries.
But it's not the humanities at
Yale are not like at Stanford
or MIT that have been tied
to the development of tools
that the technical development in the ways
that the kind of digital humanities labs
at those institutions have evolved
over the last sort of 15 years or so.
Instead, I think what we do
here, which is very powerful,
and this is where the
DH@Yale sort of working group
is a good place to get started
is to think conceptually
about how the interaction
or the interface to use Christophe's words
with computers and the
humanities allows us to think
differently, ask different questions
and go to the tools we need
really to answer the questions
that are generated by our own research.
So lesser kind of, I
would say fetishization
of the possibility of
the internet revolution
and more about thinking
in powerfully new ways
about the way in which the
binarism of the computer
and the complexity of
the humanities interact
to create new models of thinking research,
scholarship, and teaching. So thanks.
(crowd clapping)
So we're happy to take
some questions. Yeah.
- [Woman] Thank you for
a wonderful presentation.
I was curious, I've read
your history of science
piece in there, and I was curious,
how do you track or how
would we be cognizant
of when terminology can shift for things?
So descriptions of conditions or ailments
or things like that,
the language around
them evolves over time.
- So that's actually a great question.
And then this is where I
think it's also an example
of how digital humanities is
not about just plugging stuff
into a computer, right?
So I think one of the
things that's really tricky
about that kind of scholarship
is you have to do a fair
amount of preliminary work
to be able to know what your
search terms are, at all.
Right. And so that also means
working collaboratively.
And this is something that I
think humanists in particular
are not very well-trained to do
in a way that scientists really are,
which is to not think of yourself
as the generator of knowledge,
but to think of a distributed model
in which you might have to collaboratively
go to a lot of people and be like
you're 14th century specialists,
how was this thing talked
about in those texts
and then generate, you
know, your own corpus
of search terminology that
then you would be able to feed
into a number of different databases
to track perhaps contextually
then how that particular
word or phrase shifts.
But that does require, I mean,
this is actually crucial.
It does require kind of preliminary work
before you can apply a digital technique.
And so I think that often the
sense of digital humanities
is, you know, we're gonna go
and like get something quickly.
And I think (mumbles and giggles)
- Exactly the magic. Magic
thinking of digital humanities.
- And the truth is like,
it takes a very long time
to even do things like figure
out like what's my corpus.
I mean, I'm still spending
all this time thinking about
like, what is a lyric poem
in a bunch of different traditions?
Like even that terminological question,
but also the, like how
do we define the object
in a way that the computer
can understand, right.
And that binary thinking is
a huge conceptual challenge,
right? Like that is the
big work. In some ways.
The small work is the
actual stuff of plugging
it in and like hitting a button. Right.
- [Woman] Hi. Thank you so much (mumbles)
(background noise drowns out other sounds)
- So I will just say one thing,
I think that what you're
putting your finger on
is a larger pedagogical
and curricular issue
in doctoral training.
And I will say that one of the aspects
of the doctoral report that
was published last year
by the working group
for the graduate school,
was that departments need to
think about other pathways
to build in pathways,
into doctoral programs,
precisely to recognize things like
if you have to learn Python,
learning Python is like
learning Latin in a certain way.
Right. And so can we,
for instance, find ways
within doctoral training
to create time for students
to get the skills they might
need to do the scholarship
that they wanna do.
And so that is a hugely
important and big question.
In the long-term, I think
there's a lot of conversation
about how to do that in
different departments.
You should talk to your
own advisor and DGS
about ways that you can actually use that
to meet requirements in your program
because departments are
becoming flexible about this.
The shorter term answer,
I'm gonna leave that to Christophe
who has acquired many of these skills.
(Ayesha laughing)
- I so agree, and that's
a general discussion,
even in the humanities,
beyond Yale, right.
We try to, I mean, also the
question of recognition.
One thing that I think is
interesting in what you're saying
is there should be a way
to do digital humanities
with not a lot of technical skills.
And this is, I think, where for instance,
something like DH@Yale can help.
But what I mean beyond that,
is that the conceptual work
should bring questions that then someone
who is specialized can answer.
And digitally, many of
these shouldn't be at least
this is what I believe
necessarily tacky. It's great.
Of course, it's fantastic.
It allows us to think differently
it allows us to do a lot of things,
but there should be a way
to do digital humanities
without the technical skills necessarily.
This is also some kind
of support that we have.
So there would be two paths.
There is the path where
you do the conceptual work.
And you leave the technical work
to someone who is an expert,
or you put the work in, in
learning it with all that.
- I guess we might disagree
on this a little bit,
because I think, I mean, my own feeling,
and this has come out of my own experience
is you need to be conversant
at least a little bit
with some level of like
coding and other things,
because otherwise you kind of don't know
what your collaborator,
who is the technical expert
is doing, right.
So I think collaboration
absolutely is key.
And like we, as humanists
have to think differently
about models of creating
and doing scholarship.
But on the other hand,
I also think that there isn't, you know,
there's no corp out to understanding
basically how a database works.
Like, I mean, like that's
actually a complicated thing.
And like one of the
things I would like to see
in humanities training is that
we offer classes for students
who actually like get their feet wet
because in college they didn't
study statistics or whatever.
Like you kinda need to
know that stuff. Right.
- No, I, I completely agree with that.
It's about not making it frightening,
but anything that we can acquire.
And it also helped to rethink
a lot of things in the humanities.
- Thank you.
(crowd clapping)
(upbeat music)